oh
is
anna jason
she's a nutritionist from mit magical
wow and she also has the origins
wow
can you say that again
okay so i'm going to
talk about mediterranean diet
so you can get the sequel okay what is
it
what is this mediterranean diet that you
hear so much about okay so there's no
one particular official mediterranean
diet people think it is but it's not
it's really a food pattern that is
shared by countries that room the
mediterranean sea and you could put more
countries here i didn't go crazy um you
know you could add cyprus and you could
add it i don't know if that's not a
country but
it's a region i'll say region so that's
what we consider to be mediterranean
that i'm going to get into the more
specifics later
long time ago 1958 ansel keys organized
a seven-country study and those were the
countries that were in his study and he
had a hypothesis that
a diet was very related to heart disease
so he studied this for decades and then
it did show that there was a lower
prevalence of hypercholesterolemia
that's high blood cholesterol and heart
disease in populations of greece and
italy especially greek island of crete
and he attributed that to diet
the cretins had like a 90
less
heart attack or heart
problems which is huge huge yeah so he
thought oh it's their diet and what
about their diet um he thought it was
the fact yeah since then right there
have been many more studies that have
looked at this hypothesis we had the
framingham heart study which was done
here in massachusetts nurses health
study i think that was still going on
women's health initiative the
conclusions and the discussion from all
the studies in the papers
are that plants plant fats
yield better cardiovascular health than
animal fats so it's the same thing
that ansel keys discover to say that
animal fats in the abundance that
americans ate them not a good thing
as i was looking at all the studies you
know preparing for this
i was amazed
that i was amazed that
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
studies not one of them said oh
my mediterranean diet is not good
since 204 i looked at 13 studies
there is strong evidence and these are
from the studies themselves the kaboom
the researcher's conclusion strong
evidence that replacing saturated fats
with monounsaturated fats is associated
with reducing cardiovascular mortalities
or illnesses around heart disease and
how does it do that how how does
the switching of the fats
reducing bad cholesterol that's ldl
cholesterol decreasing blood
triglycerides and reducing inflammation
those are some of the mechanisms that
help
reduce cardiovascular risk
and also more recently you know diabetes
has really become the prevalence in
america and the world
strong evidence that monounsaturated
fatty acids
are associated with improving type 2
diabetes it makes people less insulin
systems so there's
more health benefits
it's not just cardiovascular health
mediterranean diet
has been
reducing alzheimer's it's been shown to
reduce parkinson's disease
reduce the risk of depression reduce the
risk of diabetes studies to show that
mediterranean diet improves brain
cognition so you think better which is
good you remember things better so
participating to the seminars yeah
you're gonna be smarter tomorrow
mediterranean diet has been shown to
protect against some cancer's breasts
and that should say prostate oh my god i
said free state see what happens with
spell check yeah okay
so yeah um and living longer which is
amazing there was one study that said
people who follow meditate you know live
like three years longer so
oh and weight loss
yeah weight management people who follow
a more mediterranean style can be more
successful at managing their weight than
a low fat diet for instance
okay so this is just a study just to
show you that they there are hundreds of
them that exist this is uh from
nutrition journal it's recent
people were following a mediterranean
diet the people that found that followed
the mediterranean diet more had less
inflammation which is involved in
disease
reduce oxidative stress you know the
free radicals higher circulating levels
of antioxidants all which are associated
with reduced risk of disease in general
so that's one study with the mid diet
here's the prostate cancer
this was done in spain
they looked at meta-analysis and they
looked at a lot of studies and said here
that they cited several characteristics
of meta diet including highly data
consumption of fruits vegetables grains
tubers legumes olive oil is the main
source of fats
low intake of animal products
and regular consumption of small fish so
another study
eating a diet with omega-3 fatty acids
can improve insulin sensitivity and
that's got to do with diabetes again
here's another study adherence to
mediterranean diet is associated with
the risk of diabetes separate from the
insulin eating a mediterranean-style
diet rich in olive oil whole grains fish
fruit may protect aging brains from
damage associated with cognitive
problems
and so here's just a quick excerpt after
reviewing the brain mris
of the older people they found that
people who followed the mediterranean
diet more closely were up to 36 percent
less likely to show brand damages
here's another study
from neurology and they're recent so
again this was protecting against
strokes
so what is it about this mediterranean
diet that can do it sounds like a
miracle diet so the first thing the
first big characteristic and i think
everybody knows is the fact that the fat
source is different in the mediterranean
compared to us and western diets and it
is olive oil and it's lots of olive oil
mediterranean diets can be up to 40
50 calories from fat
so it's a lot of fat that's not a
low-fat diet but they're not fat you see
so fat doesn't make you fat the big
characteristic here and what ansel keys
discovered
was
that or what his hypothesis was that it
this kind of fat that had healthy
benefits
and just so you know that's an omega
omega-9
and i can also tell you that's pretty
small but i just wanted to remind myself
there's there's many other compounds in
olive oil
think of olive oil as like a fresh fruit
nectar this is not an
an oil that has been highly processed to
get its fat like sesames and soy and
those are made differently this is just
the fruit and i have to mechanically get
it out it's not with chemicals it
shouldn't be anyone
but so it's so it's got a lot of fresh
compounds in there the fresher the
better there were studies that say if
you have fresh olive oil
it's healthier for you than not so good
quality olive oil okay so then
mediterranean diets also have other fats
in their diet they're not from olive oil
they're not omega-9 they're omega-6 i
know you've heard that and we never
refer to this we always call this
monounsaturated nuts and seeds sesames
cashews walnuts
those
are considered polyunsaturated fats
there's other fats in the diet fish
those in the omega-3 polyunsaturated
these are mono and these are
polyunsaturated
so fish is also very prominent in the
mediterranean diet okay the other
characteristic fresh fruits and
vegetables are prominent they are not an
afterthought the vegetables are the
highlight
of many meals
there is meat in the mood training diet
the portion is smaller
it's just not always there living
vegetarian meals
so fresh fruits and vegetables are very
very high and again this is part of the
health benefits it's not just the fats
so legumes uh and i by legumes i dried
peas
lentils beans
the other thing that is left out of many
much of the literature of fresh herbs
and spices and i'll show you later that
there are compounds in here there's
vitamins there's minerals and i think
that the key to the mediterranean diet
is that
all the foods there works
synergistically oh and then there's the
plain yogurt
and cheese and those are fermented
products i wouldn't say there's a lot of
milk milk i do not see a lot of whole
grains but it's there because of the
literature and i think that other
cultures use more like when you get more
middle eastern turkey there's boulder
etc but in greece italy we don't use
whole grains they do now because they
know it's supposed to be good but that's
not i don't think that's i don't know if
they were eating that in the 1950s maybe
they were
red wine is part of the mediterranean
diet the big difference is
they have much less saturated fat
because they use foods and how do they
get it it's because they don't eat a lot
of meat their portion is small and they
don't have it frequently like every day
the other difference right is less salty
and sweet processed foods america has
lots of these cheeses potato chips
pretzels just again i think that these
and studies have shown
these all of these fresh herbs and
spices have health benefits they're not
there just for flavor when you think
about parsley lots of vitamin c vitamin
a
flavonoids
these are compounds in foods that have
health benefits and fresh garlic another
very common thing it's not chopped
already and it's not garlic powder like
we would do here in the mediterranean
diet these are all fish and there are
dep sulphur compounds are helpful so in
1992 the mediterranean diet you know we
had our pyramid here then
a group came out with a mediterranean
diet pyramid so for those of you who
like
visuals this is the mediterranean diet
on the bottom you know we're supposed to
have the most of our foods come from
here
fresh vegetables grains
olive oil they're grouped all together
and then less protein
less dairy and then
meats and sweets are put in the same
category which will feed very little
yeah don't forget they have all this
activity here too
so this these are some mediterranean
lifestyle and behaviors that i noticed
myself when i go to greece all the time
there's no such thing as eating in front
of the tv or snacking that's not a
concept i don't know if that's india in
italy no you have your meals and you're
done there's no
no concept of that like oh well
i in my practice here at medical that's
a huge issue for us americans we're like
oh what do i snack on at night people
say
i say well if you're not helping me
don't stop uh they're sharing plates a
lot of sharing it's not always common
that everybody gets their own plate like
we do a group goes out they've had their
main meal in the daytime
so the nighttime is kind of on less food
and they share so the portions are
smaller
they have smaller plates
they have their main uh meal in the
middle of the day and there's always a
nap
which is my favorite part
and there's also lots of walking this is
another thing i notice people are
walking like in most european cities or
any big city lots of walking
okay so i'm going to show you some
common food patterns of greece
real food there's no convenience process
thing garlic in a jar and cheetos in a
bag and frozen dinner not common at all
no snack foods like bars we're obsessed
with
this doesn't exist it's fruit it's
vegetable
you know meat cheese done
but no one knows not good may meals eat
it too i think i said that
meat is a much smaller part of the meal
if it's present it's a small portion
like three four ounces which is like a
deck of cards which is what we say
should be here in this country
then a lot of one pot meals they have
lots of vegetable dishes and i have
pictures to show you that are in olive
oil and it's the main entree it's not a
side dish you will see
i hope it looks good yeah fruit is a dis
is fruit is the dessert
greeks never have desserts after the
meal and i don't know about italians
but not every day not every day when
sunday
okay
desserts are a special time for greeks
and they're eating alone like oh i'll
have a coffee and a dessert for the
other day
it's it's an event there's no dessert oh
like we do here it's all fruit is always
served at the meal so it's not a snack
and it's there
and then that's my business about the
sweets are eaten at a separate time so
these are some common foods i don't know
if you've ever heard of these who has
been to whole foods you see giant beans
in the salad bar have you seen those
okay i have some of those that you're
going to see
those are usually cooked in a big oil
dish
stewed green beans is an is an entree
you eat with a salad
a piece of bread you're done
uh bean soup you'll see i have stuff
everybody knows what stuffed grapefruit
is it's a great leaf a big leaf so it's
a green leafy vegetable and then you
stop it you take rice with lots of oil
fresh spices maybe pine nuts maybe
raisins
put it on the leaf you roll the leaf and
then you cook it these are also very
common in grapefruit boiled greens you
take beet greens you take not spinach
you take
swiss chard you just steam it or boil it
put oil and lemon on it and that's the
vegetables
yeah lentil soup and the famous spinach
pie yeah
here we make it in america that is
usually with butter in between the filo
in grease it's often
olive oil
okay these are these are mine
i made those and i had them for dinner
for lunch actually that's my little dog
dish i didn't have time to make it look
good but those are those giant beans
and this is spinach carrots garlic
they're huge yeah
yeah they're like giant lima beans in a
tomato and there's oil there if this was
a if this was a more greek greek dish
you would see the oil seeping out and i
try and make it look calorie because
you know i gotta worry about those
things and then these i got this from
the internet i thought that was a good
picture these are those string beans
this is a main dish it's not a side
again it's oil tomato onion garlic
this doesn't have a lot of oil but the
next photo is my mother-in-law's who
lives in greece and you can see big
difference you see there's a lot of oil
out there
lots and she used to put more
that was how don't forget oil and fat at
a meal keeps us full
fat when you when you have a no fat day
no fat food you're going to be hungry
and you're going to want to overeat
usually carbohydrates
yeah so these are stuffed grape leaves
and squash blossoms
so again i call this like real
vegetarian food not isolated soy protein
here's a greek salad a real greek salad
what's different about this
yes there's no lettuce
anything else
there's not half a pound of feta cheese
on here
and that creamy greek dressing which is
not great
just tomato
which is divine i love it
okay so now i have my famous tips of how
you're gonna get a mediterranean diet
here in america and by the way there was
a study i didn't put in here but it was
talking about how
transporting can you transport the
mediterranean diet to other countries
like australia and america and the study
said yes you can so there's hope for us
okay so you're gonna do it cook and eat
home more often because you know what
you're doing you have a chance to eat
healthier eating out all the time is not
a healthy activity
okay so in your cooking eat vegetarian
one or two times a week as much as you
want most people who are not vegetarians
never have just a vegan meal that
doesn't have this
which is not the healthiest thing all
those tofu
i mean tofu by itself is much healthier
than the isolated soy protein burgers
and tofu dogs and
all of that so so that's one way for you
to get a mediterranean diet is try a
more mediterranean vegetarian
meal
um okay so some of those are i didn't
have pictures of falafel or hummus but
those are also mediterranean very
healthy dishes chickpeas tahini again
the same
yeah
sesame seeds yeah good fats
yeah uh use extra virgin olive oil for
cooking salad for your cooking add that
to salads don't use salad dressing which
i think is my next tip because you don't
get a good oil in a salad dressing and
you get sugar and you get thickener and
you get
tons of salt and you get sugar and
if you can get yourself a good olive oil
put your own oil and vinegar or lemon
you'll be healthier and you'll be
getting
the flavonoids and all those wonderful
ingredients
and it tastes better at first you you
might not if you're used to salad
dressing when i was growing up we had
salad dressing that was what we had and
we loved it my brother and i we shunned
the olive oil and said well it's motor
oil oh we didn't like it
because this italian dressing was so
sweet and
sugar and spicy it's not 380 but it's
not it's
just like the greek dressing is not
there's no dressing in greece it's just
same yeah it's the same yeah and it's
healthier
so that's one way you can do it yes so i
think i've really heard the support but
what's the difference between the
extroversion the version the mod version
so
oh good it's written there yeah extra
virgin would be the first pressing
and it would not be
over acidic and over like have foul
tasting
foul flavors in it so it has to do with
the quality and like the first pressing
as opposed to because you can
keep pressing this you know get the
first extraction then keep pressing and
then you get not so good olive oil and
then you can have it mixed there was a
big scandal i was telling you about that
in a book i read big scandal with olive
oil
they mix soya oil in it because it's
very profitable et cetera et cetera so
that's the question yeah if it says pure
or if it says blended i wouldn't buy it
because they do sometimes they think
that's cute it's not bad pure is not
good pure is like the one of the last
qualities
correct
pure is inferior to extra
so it's the first pressing the extra
version is the best
and it's it's more expensive but um it's
also the most it should be the most
healthy one
the other ones are not as healthy as
this one so this is yeah
so another way you can do is steam your
leafy green vegetables branch out get
some escarole
you put it in your soups you can i boil
mine boil i steam it and i put oil and
lemon that's my side with a piece of
chicken and i might have something else
with it and that's my meal otherwise i
don't get lippy green vegetables but
this way is easy
you also can then
put lots of garlic and lots of oil in
the frying pan and cook it that way
you could do that too make your own
salad dressing with real
extra virgin olive oil so you don't use
salad dressings because there's nothing
healthy about the salad dressings we buy
nothing they're wicked salty look at
sugar
reduce your intake of desserts put some
parameters you know um around desserts
so that you have it maybe on the weekend
you have it twice a week you don't have
cookies every single day or just because
it's thursday night at nine o'clock i'm
having cookies in front of the tv
that's another thing we as americans
struggle with that we want sweets all
the time for no reason i think in these
cultures it's used more for a
celebration oh it's a holiday it's a
special time it isn't just three o'clock
on tuesday and i'll have a huge
rebecca's cookie like this
that's like a 600 calorie investment
there with butter cookies are made with
butter um here another way eat plain
yogurt yolk and put your own fruit
and maybe a drizzle the plain there's
another classic greek food greek night
honey
nuts could go here too as opposed to
those yogurts that have a lot of sugar
added to them we like sweet foods here
yes okay um have meat be a small part of
the meal fine we said that
eat fish with small bones enjoy smell
sardines necklace on packaged foods
boxed foods have this instead and then i
think that's it i have one slide that
says i'm gonna challenge you all what
can you do now so after tonight after
you listen to me and you know your diets
what can you do now
think of one item that you'd like to
change about your diet
that would lead you closer to a
mediterranean diet you're not going to
revamp your diet in a night but maybe
you could do one thing
you could try a little bit closer
so that's it
you